uh but that time is playing uh he's
playing Anton cob of normally
a place for a win and we see history
okay this is a clear sign uh he wants to
avoid uh Theory but uh he wants a game
yeah and it is really perfectly healthy
it also shouldn't give much or anything
at all if like if black uh treats it
with the respect it uh I mean if you if
you try being extremely extremely
disrespectful you could you could uh not
equalize but generally speaking
well black should be completely fine I
wonder what uh Anton means he still has
uh the option of uh playing the uh the
tsukators
A6 Magnus Carlson I'm not sorry uh it's
a strange one which I think he is I
think he is trying to to say to Anton
come on you know I'm giving you all the
time in the world play something normal
like play the qga against me now very
nice move
Bishop F5 you just want to get out E6
will be next and Bishop A3
by Anton koboff interesting move huh
yeah of course yeah you want to to
prevent uh Black from from going E6 uh
well actually you you can Castle you
know I mean that's a main point uh I
think they will this will be a very uh
uh annoying version for black because in
the slacker you actually very often want
to trade that light Square Bishop for
the Knight on a three as early as
possible because it's it's your worst
piece you don't know what to do with it
and we have already spent the tempo play
English for five so uh yeah like if
you're 64 c693 I just I think it will be
a I mean as long as I don't blame
between A5 let's maybe make sure we
don't blend like but yeah let's let's
start with the finishing development
anyway
Magnus uh is not a fan of this
particular yeah I know that's not a big
surprise yeah yeah uh as white wish can
go C4 we can start with Bishop P2
because Bishop D3 is a bit is a bit too
soft I'm gonna say honestly the more I
look at this the more I feel like this
was kind of fancy but a little bit too
fancy I think this is a healthy position
for black he has to keep bikinis on f8
but
so he just uh kept looking on the fate
and went with h5h4 just to
include the rook in the game this way 96
is so funny yeah it was not a move I
would have I would have considered very
heavily
yeah very very unusual
my history just a couple of he's just
ignoring this uh this push
just I really don't care
Mighty foxy one hook H6
yeah but this also has been burning h4h3
like
all the time being the it really is the
lessons of alpha zero are being ignored
yeah and Sita is defined played I assume
we never trade on C3 voluntarily I
assume we always just snap the 25 back
right our 924 is our best piece so what
happens if I take only four we take with
the bishop without the pawn if you think
of the pawn you really are kind of
busted position it but maybe you've made
right this would be the the equation
here do you trust that let's say 92.5
you will have enough of an attack to
justify
opening yourself up to all kinds of bad
things long term
it's quite amazing actually in this game
Magnus is broken every single opening
World possible right he's he's not
canceled his King he's put his Knight on
C6 in a queen's Pawn opening he's
throwing his uh his flank pawns down the
board but somehow it makes sense but my
intuition tells me that this shouldn't
be that good for black like long term
down the sea file I feel like there
might be some issue I wouldn't I
wouldn't love being black here I don't
think but then again I don't see
anything particularly good for white
okay playing I did two at the end of the
day uh Texas Community six yeah but to
be to be fair I think koboff is a
perfect opponent for Magnus just because
he's going for it and Magnus is so good
in this kind of against this kind of
people are just tying something and then
you can can have some counter play and
we saw it a perfect example was a match
against Nepal at the end of the match
especially playing all kind of stuff and
uh well that was not
so Knight A4 and
yeah I don't know what he did actually
that was well this whole game is just
incredibly strange just everything about
it but yeah
it's just the weirdest game except
except the results maybe no the result
is very normal but yeah just just takes
on it it makes it look so easy
four V6 yeah you'll just always
same move same move yeah it's
interesting
stress it's less fancy visual person I
want screening foreign
mate you have to play F3 I think
check
okay F2 and now I can collect but that's
much it's very different version from
from yeah obviously yeah so clever move
by the world champion
and actually we see a computer
evaluation and uh well that was probably
the best this is him tariff is uh is
watching the game
so why let's have a look sister left
are you sure that's taller than not the
the second coming
I'm sure it started okay hooky one
played by uh Anton korbov
against Magnus Carson how do we do it
when you fall anyway
how how
fancy is that very fancy very fancy very
very over this position actually yeah
and now you have to offer me a exchange
of coincidence but he's not going to
play that position no
so 24 you have to go F3 but now it's no
it's just finito wow that
yeah but Rook h e six yeah playing on
the opinion yeah
oh my
yeah
wow amazing yeah how how we can win such
games and it's gone this is move 24 yeah
very impressive game by by Magnus
Carlsen I guess Queen if I really don't
see a move here but he's taking his time
yeah why Rush he's got 20 minutes or
some 18 minutes so plenty of time in
other news
tell me
um you know on board so office Spiel are
have really got a good chance today to
to win a very tight match rating-wise
apart from board one the rest of the
games are I mean the the rate we're
talking about almost identical across
the board even well bottom board there's
a bit of a yeah an imbalance but if
office Bill win they they have yeah of
course with Magnus uh
to this third win you know I mean you
know when it starts winning
the machine is hard to stop it really is
so could be
could be an extra point for for every
matches what did you play Magnus Carson
iPad 24 of course I think mating one F3
will come because Bishop F1 uh Queen F3
you can design
anything you can design here
so Anton
we play F3 because there is nothing else
and it did play F3
I guess Magnus will win uh we'll we'll
play Queen Street
I don't think there's something better
than that
the line we saw was played actually
okay
yeah that's just exchange and pawn up
you may lose one Pawn in the mix but
yeah
no the Anton will uh
sure
foreign
G5 I guess yeah he had seen enough uh
yeah Rook H6 uh Rook H6 and then mate
yeah yeah yeah
so you breaking you you break through
and you win